although Albert Einstein's intelligence
far exceeded the average his brain was
intriguingly smaller than the average
man's a typical adult male brain weighs
around three pounds Einstein's weighed
2.64 pounds while smaller overall a
crucial section of his brain was 15
percent wider than average
the inferior parietal lobe is the region
of the brain associated with Visual and
spatial reasoning this brain area would
have been crucial to coming up with
Einstein's famous theory of general
relativity which describes how a massive
object can bend space-time around it
much like how planets move in a curved
path around the Sun in 1999 a team at
Canada's McMaster University led by
neuroscientist Sandra whittleson
discovered his parietal lobe was wider
than normal because it lacked a Groove
found in normal brains the Sylvian
Fisher also known as the lateral silkis
usually separates the frontal and
parietal lobes from the temporal lobe
however in Einstein's brain this big
crevice was largely absent the rear end
was shorter or truncated it did not
extend as far into the parietal lobe as
it does in most people's brains this
expanded Einstein's parietal lobe making
it wider than normal
when Einstein died in 1955 at a New
Jersey Hospital the pathologist who
performed the autopsy removed his brain
and kept it for himself Dr Thomas Harvey
later convinced Einstein's son to allow
him to keep it for research these labels
were added by Harvey he cut Einstein's
brain into 240 blocks and stored them in
a cardboard box in his office in a mason
jar and in a cookie jar preserved in
gelatinous material Dr Harvey
procrastinated and never actually
published any research he did create 2
400 slides containing thin sections of
Einstein's brain tissue to be examined
under a microscope and sent them off to
other scientists who revealed
fascinating insights in 2001 Dr Dalia
zaidol of the University of California
Los Angeles examined two slices of
Einstein's brain containing the
hippocampus which plays a crucial role
in learning and memory she found that
the neurons on the left side of
Einstein's hippocampus were larger than
those on the right the left hemisphere
is primarily responsible for logical
thinking analytical processing and
mathematical abilities
larger neurons in the left hippocampus
suggested stronger nerve cell
connections between the hippocampus and
the neocortex which is the command
center of the brain involved in high
level thinking in addition to the
asymmetry in Einstein's hippocampus
researchers also found that the bundle
of nerve fiber is connecting the two
hemispheres of his brain called the
corpus callosum was thicker than average
in 2013 researchers from China in the
U.S found that Einstein's Corpus
callosim denoted in red was thicker than
those in the control group of elderly
men denoted in blue and also thicker
than most of those in the younger
control group of men 24 to 30 years old
denoted in green
this increased thickness likely
facilitated better communication between
the left and right hemispheres
contributing to Einstein's exceptional
cognitive abilities
it can be likened to a wider bridge
between two cities enabling faster
transportation of people and goods and
improved overall connectivity Dr Harvey
also sent off four slices of Einstein's
brain in a mayonnaise jar to
neuroscientist Marion Diamond of the
University of California Berkeley her
study published in 1985 concluded that
Einstein's brain had more support cells
than average these red and blue
structures are called glial cells aptly
named from the Greek word glial meaning
glue they play a critical role in
nourishing and protecting the neurons
additional protection might have allowed
his neurons to function more effectively
remarkably Einstein's brain didn't show
any signs of aging even at the age of 76
his brain had no traces of lipofacin the
fine yellow brown pigment granules
associated with wear and tear in the
human brain similar to how an old car
might accumulate rust over time it's
believed Einstein Was Born This Way
rather than being influenced by
environmental factors but it doesn't
mean our brains can't change Dr Diamond
was the first to show that the brain can
change and improve at any age her work
with rats demonstrated that those who
played with mazes ladders wheels and
their companions had larger brain cells
and a greater amount of glial cells
compared to rats that were kept isolated
with no toys
the implication is that all animals
including humans benefit from an
enriched environment in impoverished
environments can lower the capacity to
learn this is now called plasticity of
the brain and it has powerful
implications for what we're capable of
achieving
according to Einstein's wishes his body
was cremated and his ashes were
scattered in a secret spot by the
Delaware River he didn't want his body
to be worshiped but Einstein's
biographer reported that he had insisted
his brain be used for research even
after nearly 70 years Einstein's brain
still has so much to teach the world
just like Einstein's brain our own
genetic makeup holds secrets about who
we are I was excited to partner with my
Heritage the leading DNA service that
helps discover your Origins okay so I'm
looking at the results for the first
time and uh wow okay I knew I was
Chinese but I didn't realize my ancestry
hails from both China and Vietnam and
also traces back to Mongolia I also have
two other ethnicities Finnish
Mesoamerican and Andean which I was not
expecting this is really interesting and
it even shows me 97 other people who I
match with so this is going to help me
start my family tree on my Heritage if
you're curious about your ancestry you
can order a kit with my custom link in
the description and use my code
newsthink for free shipping you'll also
get a 30-day free trial of my heritage's
best subscription for family history
research and if you decide to continue
you'll get a 50 discount my Heritage
will never sell or license your genetic
data you are the sole owner of your DNA
data death thanks for watching I'm Cindy
Palm
[Music]